go to any comedian and they'll tell you
about being raised by single mothers and
abusive single mothers
and it'll be a joke and they will laugh
at it my mama used to beat me with a
rope
with a robot yeah mine did too
my little brother as suburbian as it
gets
uh he had a in my parents house
he had a a shoe closet that was bigger
than most of his friends
actual room it's just for shoes
but i caught him out once with his
friends
like [ __ ] shouted you know what i'm
saying and i was like what
so i pulled him over and i said why are
you talking like that
he said you have to talk like this or
you won't get accepted he said the girls
won't like you
and the guys won't accept you as as a
friend and i was like this is insane
we weren't raised like this you've seen
no parts of the hood sir
yeah and it's funny people like my dad
who genuinely did he actually is from
the part inside of eight mile that
eminem likes to claim he's from
um and uh you know really did have a
rough upbringing but it doesn't matter
a great example know i think ben carson
is such a good
worst surrogate ever like what do you
think about donald trump
i think he might maybe we should ban the
second amendment no ben
no dr ben that's not the right answer
but um
people said well he's not really black
i'm like hold on a second hold on a
second
detroit raised to a single mother in
detroit
tried to stab her like this is not a
this is not
barack obama playing for the team he's
the all-star of the black team like if
you're going to use those standards
so it seems like even even with those
standards it's all negated
if he pulls himself out of it look
barack obama
is extra black which i don't understand
his black father wasn't around he was
raised by his white mother around mostly
white people
but all of a sudden he's mr black and i
hear them say it because he married a
black woman i'm like really well that
pretty much is the first black woman
he'd ever talked to
and it's i i believe this all had
something to do with politics you know
he could not have gotten to where he is
if he had a white wife with him
it wouldn't have played to most of
america but
he's able to go out and be the blackest
thing going when he doesn't have the
black experience and i don't understand
how black people can be well why am i
saying this because black people have
been brainwashed by
liberals and democrats for all these
years if you ever notice and you can
tell black person this
why is it that every place in america
that's very very violent
has two things in common one single
mother's two democrats
yeah well it's it's uh it's people we
won't talk about
phil advised it goes back to lyndon
johnson in the model cities program and
basically
creating an incentive for women to marry
the state
i mean he said he was going to have
those negroes voting democrat for the
next x amount of years these are well
documented quotes it wasn't because they
cared about black people it was just
like now with illegal immigrants the
votes came
cheap at that point create the division
right now
listen there's nothing there's nobody
who's more shortchanged by
the current democratic proposals
democratic party proposals with illegal
immigrants than people like my mom legal
immigrants who've come in
who've and by the way this myth i wrote
about this that immigrants
are the backbone of america no america
was
it doesn't matter whether they came here
to be american and be a part of america
the immigration wasn't the immigrant
wasn't the label it was
you became american so when you have
people coming here illegally who have no
interest in american values who have no
interest in taking part in the
experiment that is america
well guess what not only are they
cutting ahead in line but they're
screwing up and destroying the america
that all the legal immigrants sought
you literally had to have watched me
last night because we talked about this
we talked about how
the democrats are undercutting uh the
voting populace what they're saying is
well shoot we'd love to have those um
felons
so let's let the felons vote because
they'll vote for us because we'll offer
them something free
they're really just going to the lowest
common denominator and i hate saying it
but that's what they're doing
they're going people with their hands
out and saying well we'll give you a
little something if you give us
your vote because it's the cheapest way
around them getting a voting populist
and they've done that with the um the
illegal immigrants when they were saying
well we should get them
worker cards and uh driver's license so
uh and it's like they're making excuses
for these people to stay
unamerican so they get to fly their flag
of where they're from
not learn your language and all of the
things that used to be a part of
becoming american
now being a separatist in america is the
norm
that's funny you mean it's one of those
things to me that's always been
relatively common sense like
hey you broke the law what do you vote
on her next one what should the law be
um
you know you got charles manson kill the
jews well we'll take that into
consideration
we were members of the ballot box like i
mean i understand if you've served your
time
as well but there have even been
proposals for felons in prison to be
able to vote like they'd go that far
if they could do it it's just like we'll
scale it back for right now
look at what they're doing in minnesota
a guy from minnesota called me last
night and he was talking about what they
were doing with
uh these somali refugees that their
their um
governor is asking for more of them
because he knows if he gets more of them
he can increase the democratic um
fan base as i would call them because
they're fanatics yeah they're literally
voting for democrat just because they
see a d
because they believe like a lot of
people when barack obama was elected
we believe he's gonna give us free stuff
and they literally came out in public
and said
black people are gonna get free stuff
and they believe this
why would they need this and why is it
okay for them to believe it well they
got their phone didn't they
they got the phone oh my gosh i know i
know that must be the stuff from your
nightmares that obama phone lady because
she has like
every negative stereotype that the
actual white nationalists have
but i just find it so obama god is a
flower
and then the funny thing is someone go
the person clearly banded with the
camera goes yeah
what about mitt romney mitt romney fox
i just had this like a ring tone on my
phone you guys have a flower
oh it was fun matt romney sucks like i'm
sorry like again
i are you laughing because she's yes i'm
laughing because of the way she speaks
and it's just it is
everything about it is funny to me and a
lot
of this stuff is it would be even more
funny
if it wasn't true right like things
they're saying and the things you're
seeing
you hope they're caricatures of of
something
but it's not it's actually their lives
they're
actually thinking this way like i've
watched on twitter and i don't know how
much you go through
and just watch it you'll watch every
time a black person says something
that is common sense they'll say you
must be a trump voter
like how is that number one even a bad
thing like black people act like
voting for other rich white people is
somehow revolutionary
because before barack obama you pretty
much just had
one white person versus another one and
both were rich but they've convinced the
black people that the white person with
the d beside their name
is all about you and all about the poor
even though john edwards was getting 800
haircuts and cheating on his wife with
cancer but he's all about you
cheating on his wife with a with cancer
with a pregnant lady i don't think it
gets
oh my gosh the guy is just an absolute
scuzz ball
um it is one of those things if like if
we're going to be simplistic right if
we're going to
to be reductive i guess to to find a
word where people like well you know the
the
republicans are the party of the rich
okay let's go with that so
they need rich people in order to be
elected so they would have an incentive
to make you
rich because they need a majority of the
country to be rich not the one percent
one person doesn't get you elected
sweetheart
so if democrats are the party of the
poor they need a majority of the country
to be
well say stephen that's where you're
messing up that's where you messed up in
your uh
slaughtering of the advise show cause
once you talk to someone whose name is
advise show you probably probably won at
that point
but the fact is once you bring up facts
to the so-called pro-blacks to the
liberal left to the social justice
warriors
they go crazy they go nuts they shut
down johnny five needs to be rebooted
yeah well he just kept telling me you
know you don't know because you're not
black with the black experience but i
just think it's such an intellectual
cop-out
what this we got a black guy here he's
gotta have inside scoop on the advise
show name
he's got i'm sure he knows yeah i was
gonna ask you okay
he messed up number one i have a beef
with the guy because the guy literally
took all of the stuff that i was doing
he used to be a fan of my show when i
started used to be a caller in
and then he just started becoming me
like everything i did he just did it
okay so he would buy all of his stuff on
uh
class here have you seen those have you
seen those ties yes god
dwell that all changed once people
started calling you stealing this guy's
stuff
like he became the anti-me of well let
me be pro-black then because i think
he's not and i can get this audience
but the advised show came from he was
trying to spell
advice and he refused because most
people are
you you win the betting pool yeah he was
trying to spell it
and a lot of people just like if you
look most black people for some reason
can i
uh spell you your y-o-u-r-e they will
always spell it while you
are and it doesn't matter um how many
times you tell them that's not correct
they will say
oh so you think you white now instead of
like you can't correct
he doesn't even know what advice is he
should have had someone advise him on
how to spell
careful jared because this is still
being this is still the web extended you
don't want to
we want to have phil back we do i don't
think he's coming back but we called
that
yeah a long time ago yeah that was it
was and i used to make fun of him about
it that's like and i was like come on
dude
and it was funny if you look there's a
guy on um
on youtube and he's a bit slow and he
was the original
advised show but he was saying advice
so he actually took this name from a
what is the politically correct term
retirement yeah
it was a [ __ ] kid he took a [ __ ]
kid you
didn't i [ __ ] you not i mean that's fine
it's his web now
i you not did that's what he did and i
was like oh my god and then when he
talks
like i don't know if you guys have ever
seen this in an interview between him
and jessie lee peterson it's one of the
funniest
[Music]
city and i said i caught a battle of
slow wits
it's just like it's like two stupid
sloths
in a jedi battle uh
i feel you know i i take some pride in
that like
we have never had someone on the show uh
from an opposing viewpoint who either
wouldn't come back
or isn't willing to come back but he did
upload our debate to his channel
and then immediately deleted it right
because everybody kept telling dude you
got slaughtered like what happened
and it was just bad because you got to
understand a lot of us who were raised
by women
women don't have to answer questions
because well they're women and somebody
wants to sleep
with them so they can get away with a
lot more than what a man can right and
what a man a woman will do
is just give an absolution to what you
said
which shuts it down like she'll say
you'll say
when you made a stat about uh the black
holes so you're saying oh
and you're like when the hell did i just
say all but they will keep saying that
to make sure that you can no longer make
the
argument like they tell me all black
women aren't like that i'm like i never
said
they all were but here's the problem
yeah whenever
whenever you're depicted this way by
yourselves you never
argue it again go to any comedian and
they'll tell you about being raised by
single mothers and abusive single
mothers
and it'll be a joke and they will laugh
at it my mama used to beat me with a
rope
with a robot yeah mine did too
preach like this is horrible this is a
felony
i used to i swear to you i used to do is
my brother used to laugh his ass off
where someone would come out we would
tune into deaf comedy jam and i swear to
you i would just i was like a kid i was
like a smart ass kid and all i was says
and we'd clap and laugh and that was it
and literally you know who the worst is
at that the worst here's the thing
dave chappelle hysterical eddie murphy
hilarious richard pryor one of the best
i find chris rock
awful just a personal thing but worse is
that uh
leslie jones have you ever watched her
stand up
i hate with a capital eight
i hate leslie jones she's a walking
stereotype
and nobody has a problem well i know
people get mad if you say if you say the
n word but just this is her actual [ __ ]
she's
i'm watching it and she's going she's
sitting there and she's like she's like
you know
cause yeah though i shot a dunk oh no
and that's what she like
and like what so it's basketball n-word
violence and people laughing i'm sitting
there like i can't believe
i can't believe this made it out like i
was in there watching precious for
example
and there is a scene in there where
this very rotund black girl
okay um she she is
illiterate and is stealing a bucket of
fried chicken
and i'm watching this going are you
[ __ ] me
this this is what was nominated if you
ever saw the film literally an
illiterate giant
fat pregnant teen is stealing a bucket
of fried chicken
i'm going i just can't believe the left
gets a
i guess it was some commentary on like
you know it was
it was so offensively bad
well if you i did a story last week it's
not funny but there's a black guy who
got killed
while eating a chicken by the police and
i said why couldn't he have quinoa
some why did he have to have chicken
what did he
was the watermelon available like i'm
i'm looking at this and i'm thinking
like these stereotypes just come out and
they come out but the people who play to
the stereotype more than anybody
are black people themselves and then
they get mad when people repeat them
there's no way that pressure should have
been nominated for anything other than
the worst movie that year
but monique deserved the nomination for
actors she was amazing in it
right but if you look at the context of
what they're doing
in their movies they constantly do the
same thing it really
bothers me that the people who are
stereotyping black people the most are
black people
and i'm gonna go a step farther and this
is where people get mad at me the black
women are the cause of a lot of this
violence that you see in the black
neighborhoods
the numbers prove it the fact that you
see them fighting all the deck on time
when you take fathers out of these homes
it's creating these huge
problems and nobody talks about it
barack obama said black women are the
backbone of the black community and
black men need to pay child support this
is your president said this
now you're the backbone you give the
backbone some money
this is the backbone and black people
got scoliosis at this point
yes exactly they're like a duck holiday
going out west
because they have tuberculosis it is oh
my god it's uh yeah i'm i'm glad to
hear it is so nice to hear a black man
tell the truth for woods
i couldn't when that guy said and like
you know what he meant we were sitting
there like oh my god i can't believe
this guy said this
um wow it is uh
it is it is really unreal that we are at
this time and that what you say is just
i mean so much flack that you catch
for it it's it's it just is one of those
things that is one i will say this as
far as white privilege
i am definitely not beholden to a
dogmatic
racial ideology that black people are
held to
i can be and it's like you're an idiot
you're a race because you're a
republican
but i'm not excommunicated as a white
person for a black person i will
definitely say that that is a burden
that that we don't have where if you go
off the reservation
they do not play nice yeah you can vote
democrat or republican
um you can eat chicken or quinoa
you can you can uh listen to rap or rock
or country as a black person i have to
listen to rap and r b
or i'm trying to be white i have to
speak with a certain addiction or i'm
trying to be white
i have to vote democrat or i'm a sellout
literally
they call you a sellout for not voting
democrat
and if you think about where that puts
you as black people here's what i've
been dealing with
i've had people threaten my life they
put my address out on the internet
uh one woman threatened to rape and
murder my daughter
because of my youtube video well a woman
did yes
how does that go how does that happen
well because like i said on my show
black uh black females are just um
males with vaginas but now that's that's
that's another story
but the point is like she's able to say
this
and there's no backlash from the other
people they were literally saying
well he deserves it because uh of what
he says
there's a guy who's a um a big time
movie maker i guess not a big-time movie
but you may have heard him
tariq nasheed he's mr pro-black is that
the guy that's the guy who everyone on
the on
everyone's
yeah he uh made a film a few films
called hidden colors
and it's supposedly about uh how black
people are magical and melanin is great
and it cures everything
and white people are trying to siphon
melanin out of black people
now melanin is what gives us our skin
color but the same man who made
this great film about how great melanin
is also has a character on youtube where
he's making fun of me
the character's name is crispy
he's making fun of him because he's so
black because i'm so black
and all the black people laugh at this
character called crispy
because he loves white women and cocaine
and all he does is
help white supremacy now black people
who are saying that
melanin is magical laughs at black
people who are my color
if you grew up in a black man i don't
even think of you as that black i knew a
guy from barbados who
i mean i swear to you at our graduation
dance you shut off the lights
with nature's camouflage it was so dark
i don't even see you as that like he is
like in the middle of the spectrum
well now black people have been so
whitewashed in america that
they the biggest form of supremacy that
faces most black people every day
is black supremacy not white supremacy
blacks make it harder for blacks to live
blacks make it to where if you move out
of the neighborhood you're a bad guy if
you talk different you're a bad guy in a
way they're enslaving themselves yeah
thank you
yes that's what's happening blacks are
held to this weird standard
of uh failure and i remember a friend of
mine
um who dropped out of college so he
could sell dope i [ __ ] you not
because he was his reasoning was
while in college the people kept making
fun of him saying he's trying to be
white and he's changing he's different
and he had lived his whole life around
these people these were his friends
he wanted their acceptance so he was
willing to ruin his future
gosh that's that is absolutely awful um
but also the problem with that too is
then you get like with the trump thing
you get into far alt-right where they do
make it about race there are legitimate
people now we're like no they just have
a lower iq
uh no it's just it's not a cultural
thing it's just a race why why are black
why are they so poor off in africa and i
i understand
i understand what they're trying to say
but even if you look at it it's because
of
horrible uh political systems and
culture
really it is true now you have to say
well why does that happen wherever like
in these black nations all right that's
a conversation have but they want to
make it about
melanin therefore inferior and that's a
real problem too and
and i feel like um you're seeing more of
that
because they've been forced to reject
what we know to be true for example
black people
commit disproportionately more crime and
if you say that you're a racist and so i
think you have a lot of people now who
are going you know what all right fine
i'm going to
go full blown racist as a rejection of
it well
i brought up the 52 staff
and even when you say black's only 13 of
the population if you break it down to
who's actually committing the crimes
it's only about five percent of the
population that's doing it it's a
demographic
of males between a certain age that's
doing this
but to say it makes you a racist just
for me to say it makes me an uncle tom
or sellout
and it's strange that you cannot hold
black people accountable but white
people are supposed to hold other white
people accountable think of it
yeah no it's it's a good point i will i
will say this too you know i did have a
a black person
once uh tried it's funny someone told me
they said this was white boy punking
uh one of my my black friends at church
when i told them the story i didn't know
if that's a term that's a term he used
so i have a dog hopper he's a doggo
argentino uh so
for people who don't know it looks like
an all white pit bull mixed with a great
dane
so you know listen in the inner cities
were you know in michigan
uh they were over bred because people
thought oh this is like a bigger than a
pit bull a little bit but they're not
fighting dogs they're hunting dogs and
so they've been discarded so he's a
rescue
well i was driving to uh texas for
thanksgiving
and i stopped by choctaw casino and i
was just letting hopper go to the
bathroom so big gleaming white very
handsome dog
and a black guy came up and he just said
he said oh man thanks you found my dog
i said sorry people get mad at the
impression i said it's just i'm just
doing impressions of whoever it is so
get over it people and i said
no this is not your dog he said yeah i
know the man that's that's my dog that's
my dog that's that's a dog of argentino
that's my dog
i said nope sorry this isn't your dog
he's uh he's actually from michigan so
no man you but i ain't even lying to you
you better give me my he started walking
up to me
and so i took hopper i put him in the
back of the car i closed and i locked it
and i walked right up to him and i said
that's not your dog don't come any
closer and he
oh my bad my bad oh my dog's not fixed
and he walked he walked away
um it changed at the drop of a dime and
my friend said he said yeah he said a
lot of these
people are taught that that white people
are afraid of them he said a lot of
times pit bulls are rescues
and so you have a lot of white people
who just go they're rescuing a pit and a
guy goes oh it's my dog and i go oh
i'm sorry and they give them the dog
because they figure maybe the dog got
lost he said that's very common and he
said we use the term like punking
and he was very surprised that you
didn't go along with it
is that have you ever seen the movie war
dogs
no you need to see it number one it's a
good movie but number two
uh uh jonah hill the exact same thing
happened to him
he was having a uh he shows where he
walks up to these black guys and he's
uh buying weed from them he gives them
500
they take the money and then they just
look off they sit there and he's like
you know where's my product and they
said
excuse me white boy he's like where's my
product
they were like you didn't you don't have
any product he said but i just gave you
money
they said you didn't give a [ __ ] white
boy and you better walk off
does he want him yeah well he says oh
okay my bad well he walks off but he
goes to his car and he pulls out an ak
but this is something that happened when
i was young i remember and i hate to
admit it
i took a white dude's jordan's i took a
white dude's nintendo
he gave he i was like let me borrow it
and and i could see the look on his face
because he knew i already had like three
of his things and he knows borrow means
you're not getting it back but he still
did it
he still did it because he opened his
ass so
so a lot of like well yeah and that's
the problem they run into when
they they can't i mean that's one thing
i've always talked about this and we
have to let you go because i could go
all day with this when i wear a blue
t-shirt or blue anything in my glasses
i have had i can't count how many people
black people
say you look like clark kent and i think
the big reason is just because they're
not used to seeing
a pretty big white guy with glasses so
kind of nerdy but also
bigger than them um and so i do i
definitely have run into you know in
in grappling for example in brazilian
you know presented to judo
where um there's this assumption that
you're intimidated but it all goes away
once you get on the mats um
so it's it i've kind of encountered it
but you know i didn't know if it was an
actual thing so
well thanks for your transparency you
took nintendo and jordan's
yes i did and he can't say anything
about it because the statute of
limitations is done
it is true though i will say a lot of
white people are absolutely terrified of
black people
i mean even the progressive liberals a
lot of them
are are scared and um they don't want to
admit it um
you know my family goes to a church does
it say 40 black
40 white and 20 other i've been around
it so much
um but even then i would be lying if i
were to say you know if i'm in an area
of detroit or if i'm in an area of south
dallas and uh you know not someone like
you i wouldn't think twice but people
who are mimicking criminal culture uh
even if they're white i guess at that
point so it's a moot point pants down to
their ankles yeah i'm gonna be on alert
well thank you think about it and i want
you to tell your liberal friends if you
love black people so much and you think
the people in the inner city are being
mistreated why is your home
around white people even tariq nasheed
mr pro black talk
um make all these hidden color films
guess where he lives
right in the hollywood hills so he
doesn't live around any of those
so-called black people that he's
standing up for what does
that tell you you don't believe the
stuff you're saying yourself
ice cube tried this once he tried to
live in a in the neighborhood when he
was
broke away from nwa because he was
saying he's down and he's going to stay
around
amongst blacks he explains why he moved
he said
ah they kept robbing me because they
knew i had money
nobody nobody uses the words white
supremacy
uh white supremacist um ray soldiers
more than him on his timeline it's like
he's getting paid per person
there's no you mean to recognition he's
also full-time he's also a dumbass
because the color is not hidden
it's the color purple we've all learned
this
sorry that was a horrible joke but uh oh
my gosh yeah
i i need to i didn't know he was a
filmmaker spike lee is just
awful awful and because he's black knows
a shitty filmmaker he's he's never
really made a
watchable film beyond maybe do the right
thing
malcolm x to me i like oh i didn't
realize that was him but that's because
you're kind of beholden to the actual
story and even then he screwed that up
by sticking himself in as a character
that's like quentin tarantino's like
george lucas yeah yeah
or like quentin tarantine whenever he
puts himself in you're like ah ah
the camera is specifically not made for
these nooks and crannies in a face
right and he just gets worse as he ages
it's it's a bad deal
oh it's gross let's think about it guys
you have to just realize that a lot of
these people are getting paid off of
other people's mis uh
being miserable and as your producer
stated he just says race soldiers race
this race that
all day he's playing to people's
insecurity he's playing to people not
they're really a lot of these blacks are
looking for an answer
and they're from the wrong places yeah
here's here's a question for you
this is my blacklight question i've been
thinking about today um
since we have one of these colored folk
on
but but really if follow my logic here
this is what i'm trying to process if
black lives matter if the big part of
the goal is to let you
uh make you aware of the racism that's
always existed that's always been around
that's always been going on uh you just
haven't been they're just bringing it to
surface
i have seen so many friends on facebook
constantly saying you know what my whole
life i'm 30 something years old my whole
life i've never been afraid of police i
was
i wasn't even you know never had any bad
experiences but also now every time the
light's going on in the back of my car
i'm afraid i'm going to die people who
say you know i was i'm now more afraid
of the police than i ever was of
the gang life in my you know growing up
you know the crips and the bloods in my
neighborhood
um is that a victory for black lives
matter for them for so many people to be
afraid that when they never were if this
is so prevalent why if they
are just now aware of this if it's been
going on for so long
it's a lie you may not like chris rock
but he said it he said i'm not afraid of
al qaeda i'm afraid of our [ __ ]
well he also had a hilarious thing about
not about uh not getting shot by the
cops remember that bit not getting your
ass kicked
now it's like don't run if a cop have to
run after you
he's bringing an ass kick in with him
and he's like these basic tips but of
course now
he would support the black lives matter
and all this stuff you know because
and and again i'm not for excessive
force and that's one of the things we
need
push that the cops are not being trained
correctly but you're right
most black people are not just sitting
there afraid now what i am afraid even
though i have money
i'm still afraid when i swipe my atm
card that it just might have no money in
there
just that's a byproduct of being black
you just think it's not gonna work
or you think when you when you get
pulled over sometimes i think he's just
gonna give me a ticket like
i can't unzip my i can't slightly unzip
my pants and get out of a ticket
that doesn't work for me like it does
for a woman to slightly pull a shirt
down
so i understand but then a white guy
called my show last night he said look
i'm uncomfortable when the cops pulled
me over too yeah we both are
yeah i mean i've always talked about
that was it i mean jared has this
concealer
that's and you're all fine hey and most
of the time
and i've i've known officers whether
you're black or white if you have a
concealed carry and you're really
uh straightforward you said you've been
let out of tickets because you're like
officer have my right to carry and they
appreciate well yeah the first thing
that says like hey that's a smart move i
appreciate you know
he's glad i'm out there um but the first
when you first walked up you're like
how do i am i doing this right my hands
the right place
am is my wallet not behind my gun where
i have to reach to my past my gun to get
my wallet like it's a terrifying
experience if you
until like you know it eases up as a
matter of fact every time i see uh
cop lights in my my heart like jumps out
of my chest
me too yeah and i have my concealed
carry and the weird thing is
you said that you say up front
that you have it i'm afraid to do that
if they're just pulling me over for
speeding i don't say anything and just
try to let them give me the ticket and
let them go
because i honestly think that's going to
lead to something else
uh just like the youtube video showed
these two men walking down the same
stretch of road
both of them had an ak legally were able
to carry them
the white guy was able to walk and not
be harassed the black guy
same thing in the same area and
literally they kept calling 9-1-1 on him
there is an element of sure people are
used to looking at something or seeing
something and television doesn't help
and black people don't help let's just
call it what it is white people are
putting out
images of black people being violent but
i'm one of the black people who put out
an image of black person being violent
by stealing uh jordans and
edmonton i will say this again just
just not really knowing the situation
processing it if i see a white guy open
carrying an ak
i right away think that they are a far
right libertarian making a point
because i never see it if i do see a
black person with an ak my mind doesn't
go there right away because i also know
there aren't many far right wing black
people
that it's much more likely that the ak
is for something else
that would just be my quick again you
know discrimination
uh generalizations are evolutionary
psychological
advancements to try and protect your
life now if that black guy had a
big old fat belt buckle and a
confederate flag hat you probably would
associate him
with the far right groups at that point
you thought it was cowboy troy but
that's a whole nother
cowboy exactly the worst but i will say
well same thing i will say you know
uh was it we saw that guy there at the
public park black guy
shirtless greasy like randy from trailer
park boys with his open carry
gun and he did you could see his boxers
it was weird it was weird
and we were like okay we immediately
were like well not gang activity because
he's open carrying but a shirtless black
guy greasy looked out of it
uh they called him a peacekeeper or
something like that kind of policing the
area
yeah i don't know but my reaction to him
would have been very different if he was
just
dressed as any of us are now or a polo
or whatever it is and open carrying but
it's like
what's not so much that you're black and
open carrying is set your greasy
shirtless
with your pants lope and this is just a
bizarre picture
well we don't talk about it i'm glad you
brought it up and i hope you talk about
that more
i'm one of those proponents of if we're
really going to be so-called the
liberals because the liberals are the
main people trying to shut down free
speech
free thought only they are supposed to
have it and only you're supposed to
agree with it
if you're going to be honest in life
everyone has their
prejudices and those are the things
or everyone has their whatever you want
to call it but those are the things that
helped us
evolve and survive as people and i'm
tired of someone saying
you should treat all people the same no
no no no no you're not
just like i don't let everyone into my
house if a guy is coming to my door
and it's four in the morning and he's
breathing hard and he's got
dirt all over his face and his shirt's
torn i'm probably not gonna just let him
in my house
if a female comes to the door and she
looks like halle berry i'm letting her
in
there's a difference i'm discriminating
i'm sorry at that point it's probably a
dream
right right i need to wake up
as a kid i was terrified of asians let
me tell you why
because i always i've always sort of had
the gift of gab and i've been able to
talk myself out of bad situations
being raised around a lot of like heart
like chinese people
uh barely speak english there was no
negotiating at all
it was you know this happened we had a
guy who ran our prank shop you know we'd
go get like exploding bubble gum and
stuff
and uh he would give us stuff that would
like be broken and it wouldn't work
remember he gave me like a one of those
uh
you pull out the gum and it snaps your
finger you know like a little mousetrap
and we're going back i was like this
this this is uh this is broken he's like
no no the ac smack not broken you
no i was like well i just give it return
for another one sale final
sale final final sale there was a kid
thinking like oh my gosh if this guy
wanted to kill me i wouldn't be able to
talk my way out of it because there was
no
it didn't mean like logic or any kind of
empathy i remember thinking of them as
very robotic
as a kid and being slightly afraid of
asian people
well you should have said though
exactly but i remember like there was no
no you you just saw me
this is broken it doesn't sale final
sale final i remember that legos
yesterday i'm sitting there like
like no one else in my experience at
that point i still have to go and order
your chinese takeout
yes exactly no at that point nowhere
else like i was like oh i'm sorry kid
you know it's a 75 cent thing
you were used to people but the the
chinese guy sale final like didn't care
well black people apparently had the
same experience because if you remember
the movie
minister society which is old remember
what the hurry up and buy like that's
what it was
it's true and i do the black people are
uh a lot of them are afraid of korean
shopkeepers
yeah yeah because they they just blow
people away they're weaving korean
shopkeepers may take the weave away so
yes if you like this video subscribe or
click
what's playing next to me it's taken
from the full show that's right every
week
the full two something hour podcast
that's never going daily
and it's never going daily stop asking
but it's free
you can go watch it play it in your car
uh it's better than texting and driving